la comédie-française l'avare de molière
revisité dans une mise en scène
résolument moderne à paris qui
apprécieront peut-être les puristes
reportage françoise roy et jean françois
chevet est une marque comme cet homme en
noir genre danseurs de tango argentin 7
harpagon en vend entremetteuses s'expose
in étonnant non c'est bien là bas et
nous sommes bien à la comédie française
une version rajeunie
il es poussière et revisité par andreï
serbanne un metteur en scène qui a
souhaité donner une idée plus large au
chef-d'oeuvre de molière c'est ouvrir
leur tendresse de sa taille et leur
coeur et trouver les endroits par les
sont sensibles je trouvais très
intéressant que ce soit pas une nouvelle
mise en scène autour de ce personnage
que ce problème de maladie avec
l'avarice mais une l'histoire d'une
famille où les enfants se plaignent
d'avoir ce père là et finissons se
plaignent en force de se plaint d'être
pire que lui ça ce projet leïla donné au
départ et ça nous a réunis coffre-fort
mais son suspect jamais me fier mais
tient justement une franche à morges à
wohlen et c'est toujours la première
chose que l'on va attaquer des yeux des
mains gantées des portes qui s'ouvrent
et se ferment comme dans un songe le
pathétique le bouffon qui alterne avec
le romanesque bref une vision de
l'avarice tu surréaliste un peu à la max
ernst
il est tellement proche de moi ce
personnage que j'ai l'impression à
chaque fois que je me sens sur le
plateau j'ai un bus de molière je le
regardais jeune homme demande de m'aider
j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils me disent
ces problèmes ce que tu fais chaque
samedi coûte c'est pas mal ce soir
'nos vous fassiez faire un habit allant
jouir de l'allégresse que c'était le
jour nous présent après trois siècles de
représentations figées par les éternels
alexandrins il existe la preuve en est
faite de nouvelles subtilités à
découvrir chez les classiques
c'est peut être cela la magie du théâtre
et de l'air du temps qui passe
génération après génération